there seems to be a certain level of
pride
to say
i'm a gangster versus a racketeer in
your world like we're not in your world
we don't know your world but in your
world how is a gangster scene how was a
racketeer scene in the streets it's
almost like if i'm in the military
you know i wonder is it like infantry
versus support what does that look like
racketeer against gangster
that's a great analogy i mean infantry
versus support you know when you're in
the infantry you're going out and you're
putting yourself on the front lines and
there's somebody in the way in the back
supporting you they all deserve respect
they're all part of it yeah but i mean
the main guy on the front lines you got
to give him a lot of respect he's the
guy taking the bullets giving them
i mean he's the guy who's making them
happen so you got to respect him a
little bit more than the guy in the back
but um they're all part of it so i never
looked at it and when i was in the
military as well i never looked at
somebody who was in the back
that he was less than me but uh
he was in the back
i was in the trenches and i really
wasn't in the trenches i was in the
infantry but i was on communication
so
in the back we set up a tent
where they communicate with the front
lines and back and forth i'm the schmuck
who ran back and forth to the front line
to talk with the guy who's got the radio
or
what there was problem so i'm i'm back
and forth
so i knew what it was to sit in the back
and i knew it was i'd be sitting on the
front lines i'd rather sit in the back a
little bit
but
you have bullets [ __ ] flying around
and where was this exactly
uh in training okay training yeah i
never went to vietnam for vietnam this
is for okay gotcha yeah i was in durham
event and i wore but i never
went there you needed a full year i only
had eight months left so they wouldn't
ship you out
so and then they asked me when i go to
the va
did you have boots on the ground
yeah i did in bensonhurst brooklyn i had
boots on the ground not in vietnam
you know he went to vietnam except he he
was in vietnam to party not yeah it was
a great time well after the war was over
yeah yeah yeah
early 2000s yeah
different story different stories right
back nancy tran so
so so racketeering and gangster like
when when guys that listen to your
podcasts or guys that listen to
interviews and they're in the world
maybe they were an associate maybe they
were made i'm not even talking about the
capos underboss or anybody that's you
know had a rank
those who were an associate or those who
were made men
how do they look at visually like i'm
really curious how do they look at a
gangster
uh versus a racketeer if they if they
walked up to a racketeer and it's an
earner as big as sami as big as michael
the kind of money that he was making do
they look at him and did they say wow
this guy's making money for a lot of us
so respect for that and then do they
look at a gangster and say i better not
cross this guy what is that level of
mindset in your world not our world in
your world
well to put it in your world how do you
look when you go in a room and there's a
pit bull and there's a poodle
what do you think and how do you feel
you're saying a racketeer is a poodle
well compared to a pit bull
he's a pool
yes
so
that's an interesting analogy to say the
least i didn't think i don't really have
a comment other than that's interesting
well i mean you know i'm a gangster
you're a racketeer that's what i just
learned because i make the money and you
deal with other stuff yeah well a pit
bull bites right so you're gonna have
well you know i'm going to be a little
more cautious than this i got you poodle
and the pit bull you know the poodle
makes money at shows
shows and and and you got to respect
that he's won medals and you could sell
his little puppies and stuff like that
for big money and so you respect both of
them you love both of them they're dogs
yeah semiconductors one's a little more
dangerous than the other one can the can
the gangsters
do they need to coexist meaning do you
need to have racketeers and gangsters
can you just have gangsters can you just
no you do you gotta have a yin yang kind
of a thing how does it work
it's
listen we respect the entire thing if
you burnt that saint in your hand and
you became a made guy we respect you no
matter what
we respect the life
so we respect whatever you are somebody
proposed you to become a friend of ours
and we respect that if we don't respect
that we could die we can't raise our
hands to one another i can't raise my
hands to a guy who's a racketeer and say
i'm a tough guy and he's not i can't
[ __ ] this don't work
everybody has equal respect david is
that mike on
is that mike on no is that mike on kai
it was on now you turned it off okay
good okay that's good i'm hearing stuff
okay uh excellent did y'all answer your
question for you that racket versus
gangster i want to make sure that he was
the reason why we're asking this
question is because adam's thinking
about being a gangster and we're trying
to hold him back from doing it because
he wants to i don't think he's convinced
he doesn't want to do la cosa nostra he
talks about like kosher no stress it's
what he wants to do that's appropriate
yeah he could uh go to uh you know a
jewish deli and
and hit it up thank you but you've been
you said very quite candidly last night
that you got along very well with jews
and the italians and the jews coexisted
and you guys did things together would
you expound upon that absolutely
absolutely i always did
in bensonhurst brooklyn when i was a kid
it was predominantly an italian jewish
neighborhood we had a house my mother
and father and us in the middle on both
sides there was three houses attached on
both sides there was jewish families
and we had a tremendous respect i told
stories a long time ago my friends would
break my balls you're jewish
they would call you jewish yeah you're a
jew i said i'm not i'm italian what are
you talking about they said in the house
when we put up the christmas lights and
the window there was the hanukkah lights
the menorah the menorah the shamash was
right here the leader right so i went in
and asked my father
why are we putting candles in the window
that are jewish people think we're
jewish
he said because our neighbors the
holiday is very similar
and respected neighbors they're jewish i
put the menorah in the window
and i learned things like that when i
shoved little snow for my own house i
did it for them
and uh
they always took care of me they had
fish they would call me and sammy come
in my house they bought i knew i had a
fish tank they would buy me fish i
always had great relationships with
jewish people sammy what's the story
about the the jewish community i talked
to myron sugarman i don't know if you uh
uh know the name myron sugarman or not
no i had him on and he was a
he was a a jewish gangster
he calls himself the last jewish
gangster and he was telling stories
about the jewish
mob back in the days how tough they were
how strong they were and partly he
talked about how they trained italians
because they were one of the first that
what do you know you're a history guy
what do you know what the history of the
jewish mob and the affinity with the
italian mob did they try was there a
training
going on was there some kind of a you
know how you're talking about maya
lansky yeah
they were very powerful in the mob
media corporate it was mostly jews
say that one more time murder
incorporated the shooters were mostly
jewish interesting why was that
i don't know ask lucky luciano when you
see him okay but uh lucky luciano was
completely close with maya lansky and a
lot of jewish gangsters he grew up with
them he liked them they were around him
and they were tough
i mean bugsy siegel
these people were tough people might
have incorporated there was a bunch of
them
well it comes down um the actual history
of it comes from the original
immigration the jews were the first real
wave of immigrants in lower manhattan
and then you know we talked about this
with the irish corned beef on st
patrick's day is actually the jews
teaching the irish how to cure their
meat there was no refrigeration they
couldn't afford it so it's kind of the
same thing in the in the early american
you love this word zeitgeist the the
eastern europeans and the jews were the
first wave of
uh immigrants and then the italians and
the irish were the second wave so we
kind of learned from them coming over
here
[Music]
so if you enjoyed this little short
segment from the podcast that we did
here's another short segment to watch or
if you want to see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody
bye-bye
[Music]